Tôi biết đưa nó trong ngày bây giờ tỏa bà chỉ chính hộ sối động với phía hộ sư cho ý hoặc sư càng két điều trên hạc,
hộng ra, trên dịch hột tổng tạo trở rộng quay ở bên hông mốt.
Chúng tôi chung bối càng tuyền tận tại nó lực quan trọng lại và như bị tế liệt quan toàn,
vì xung đô tại Iran.
Cú thể phát biểu tại nhà trắng.
Ông trọng trọ biết nhiều cu ra đã bây tổ sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn,
trong một số đông mình lâu năm lại không hưởng ở nguyên để nghĩ của Washington.
Ông trọng bởi việc Mỹ dành dựng một lực bảo vệ các nước này trong nhiều năm,
như khi cần hỗ trợ họ lại tỏa ra không những tình.
Bột số đông mình của Mỹ như đất,
tế bà nhà với ta lia cho biết,
hiện chưa có kế hoặc điều tạo tất cả các bạn.
Bắc liên thì nhận mạnh,
việc tham ra cần có quyết quên từ liê hộc quốc,
liên mình cho ông phóng tổ chú kế gướng bó đại thời gian nào tổ,
đông thời cho rằng chính dịch quan sử của Mỹ và Israel tại Iran không phải nhập buổi của nào tổ.
Súng rồi, giữ liên quan Mỹ Israel đã bước sẵn tổn tổn tổ ba,
theo biển hôm ốt,
nơi vẫn chuyển quan,
hà miệf hình trong dầu mò và khi tự nhiên hóa lòng,
lửa nửa tổn cầu,
gần như bị phong tòa,
khiến giả nó lượng tăng và làm dưới lên lông lại là phát trên thì chúng của tế.